Of our five points
will be to end the abuse of the health and care visa.
We will stop overseas care workers
from bringing family dependents
and we will require care firms in England
to be regulated by the Care Quality Commission
in order for them to sponsor visas. Yeah. Yeah.
Approximately 120,000 dependents
accompanied 100,000 care workers
and senior care workers in the year
ending September 2023.
Only 25% of defendant dependents
are estimated to be in work,
meaning a significant number
are drawing on public services
rather than helping to grow the economy.
We recognise,
we recognise that farm workers do great work
in our NHS and health sector,
but it is also important
that migrants make a big enough financial contribution.
Therefore, we will increase
annual immigration health surcharge this year by 66%
from £624 to £1,035
to raise on average around £1.3 billion
for the health services of this country
every year. Second.